WE'VE SEEN AIRED OUT IN THE
PRESS.
SO ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO READ IS THINGS
THAT WE ALREADY KNOW.
>> JOHN, DO YOU THINK THE
REDACTED VERSION OF THE
AFFIDAVIT WILL REVEAL MANY NEW
DETAILS?
>> I THINK IT COULD.
I THINK THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT
TOOK THE JUDGE OVER TO THE SIDE
OF RELEASING THIS MATERIAL.
THAT WAS HIS INCLINATION.
HE WANTED TO SEE A STRONG CASE
BY JUSTICE AS TO WHY NOT AND HE
DIDN'T GET THAT.
THEY OBVIOUSLY DID COME FORWARD.
BUT I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT TRUMP
IS GOING TO BE HAPPY WITH THIS
DOCUMENT GIVEN THE FACT IT WAS
AN ADVOCACY DOCUMENT WRITTEN TO
PERSUADE THE JUDGE TO FIND
PROBABLE CAUSE TO UNDERTAKE A
SEARCH.
THAT ISN'T A DOCUMENT THAT'S
GOING TO PUT A LOT OF PLUSES IN
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
TO THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
SO I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE VERY
UNHAPPY WITH WHAT HE FINDS AND
WHAT COMES OUT AND IT WILL NOT
BE GOOD FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> JUDGE GERTNER, DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO YOU FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM DIDN'T
TAKE AN OFFICIAL POSITION IN
COURT ON WHETHER THE AFFIDAVIT
SHOULD BE RELEASED?
THEY SAID A LOT OF STUFF ON TV,
BUT IN COURT THEY WERE SILENT.
>> BECAUSE -- BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
WANTING -- BECAUSE HE'S DEEPLY
AMBIVALENT.
IF HE CAME OUT IN COURT AND SAID
I ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE PRESS
THAT WANTS THIS STUFF RELEASED,
IF HE WERE THEN CHARGED, HE
WOULD HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
SAYING THAT THE RELEASE OF THIS
INFORMATION IS WHAT PREJUDICED
HIM WHEN IN FACT HE WAS THE
ARCHITECT OF THAT RELEASE.
SO HE'S PLAYING BOTH GAMES AT
THE SAME TIME.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> ANDREW, ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE
INVESTIGATION IS STILL IN ITS
EARLY STAGES.
WHAT WOULD THE FBI'S ROLE BE IN
THE PROBE RIGHT NOW?
WHAT IS THE DIVISION OF LABOR
ESSENTIALLY BETWEEN THE BUREAU
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
WHO'S ULTIMATELY DRIVING THE
TRAIN?
>> SURE.
SO YOU HAVE REALLY TWO VERY
SEPARATE BUT TIED TOGETHER
EFFORTS GOING ON HERE, ANDERSON.
SO THE ONE THING IS THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE POSSIBLE
CRIMES THAT WERE LAID OUT IN THE
SEARCH WARRANT.
SO VIOLATIONS OF THE ESPIONAGE
ACT AND OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO YOU'VE GOT AGENTS LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY AT WHAT TRUMP
OFFICIALS SAID AND DID IN THIS
COURSE OF CONDUCT OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF IN RETAINING THE
DOCUMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AGENTS THAT
ARE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY AT THE
MATERIAL ITSELF, TRYING TO COME
UP WITH A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT,
ESSENTIALLY TO BE ABLE TO SAY
HOW MUCH HAVE WE POSSIBLY LOST
IN TERMS OF THIS VERY SENSITIVE,
MOST CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEOS FROM THE
AREA AROUND THE BASEMENT WHERE
THE DOCUMENTS ARE STORED,
THEY'RE TRYING TO IDENTIFY
EVERYONE WHO COMES UP ON THOSE
VIDEOS, THEY'RE INTERVIEWING
THOSE PEOPLE, SO IT'S TWO VERY
COMPLICATED AND LABOR INTENSIVE
EFFORTS UNDER WAY AT THE SAME
TIME.
>> JOHN, DO YOU THINK HEAVY
REDACTIONS CREATE MORE
CONFUSION?
I READ ONE FORMER PROSECUTOR
DESCRIBE IT AS A POTENTIAL
RORSCHACH TEST AND PEOPLE READ
INTO IT WHAT THEY WANT TO SEE IN
THOSE BLACK BOXES.
>> THAT'S A GOOD METAPHOR
BECAUSE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
I GUARANTEE YOU THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AND TRUMP HIMSELF
WILL FIND LOTS OF REASONS TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT ALL THAT BLACK
SPACE.
THEY'LL GO ON ENDLESSLY ABOUT
HOW THINGS ARE DARK CONSPIRACIES
ARE GOING ON AND THIS IS
EVIDENCE OF IT.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY WILL ARGUE.
AND NO ONE CAN REFUTE IT UNTIL
THE REST OF THE DOCUMENT IS
RELEASED, IF AND WHEN THAT EVER
HAPPENS.
>> IT WILL BE LIKE WORDLE, WE'LL
ALL FIGURE OUT HOW MANY LETTERS
CAN FIT INTO A CERTAIN SPACE.
JUDGE GERTNER, IS THERE ANY
SCENARIO WHERE THE RELEASE OF
THE AFFIDAVIT COULD COMPLICATE
THINGS IF IT GOT TO THE CASE OF
CHARGES AND TRIAL?
>> SURE.
WE HAVE TO STEP BACK TO SOME
DEGREE.
THE ESPIONAGE STATUTE INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DISSEMINATED
INFORMATION, NOT JUST PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COLLECTED DEFENSE
INFORMATION.
AND IT'S A VERY BROAD STATUTE,
DEALS WITH UNLAWFUL TRANSFER,
UNLAWFUL DESTRUCTION, AND
UNLAWFUL RETENTION.
SO IT'S POSSIBLE -- AND SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THEY WOULD
CONCLUDE IF IT'S A MERE UNLAWFUL
RETENTION THAT THEY DID NOT WANT
TO CHARGE ANYONE, RIGHT?
THAT'S ALWAYS POSSIBLE, THAT IT
WAS JUST A WHOOPS.
NOW, WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE, IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN A WHOOPS GIVEN
THE STEPS THAT THE PRESIDENT
TOOK, THE FORMER PRESIDENT TOOK
TO KEEP THE STUFF IN HAND.
BUT THE DANGER HERE IS IF ANYONE
IS MENTIONED IN THAT AFFIDAVIT
QUITE AFAR FROM THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO THEN IS NOT
CHARGED.
THAT'S THE WHOLE CONCERN HERE.
THIS IS AN INVESTIGATIVE
DOCUMENT, AN AFFIDAVIT, NOT A
CHARGING DOCUMENT.
AND PRESUMABLY AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THE INVESTIGATION, THEY MAY
SAY, WELL, WE'RE GOING AFTER YOU
OR YOU, BUT NOT YOU.
AND WHAT THE RELEASE OF THIS
INFORMATION COULD DO IS TO HURT
THE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T CHARGED
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, HAVE SERIOUS
IMPACT ON ANY PROSECUTION GOING
FORWARD.
PARTICULARLY GIVEN A PRESIDENT
WHO HASN'T -- YOU KNOW, WHO
SEEMS TO HAVE NO PROBLEM CALLING
PEOPLE OR, YOU KNOW, THREATENING
PEOPLE.
>> ANDREW, LOGISTICALLY, HOW
DOES IT WORK?
IF THIS IS AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION AND THEORETICALLY
IN AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION THE
FBI WOULD BE CONTACTING PEOPLE,
CONDUCTING INTERVIEWS, GIVEN ALL
THE DRAMA SURROUNDING THE
SEARCH, WOULD THAT HAVE JUST
FOR -- I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S POLITICAL REASONS OR ANY
REASONS, WOULD PEOPLE IN THE FBI
BE JUST LIKE LET'S PUT
EVERYTHING ON HOLD WHILE THE
FUROR DIES DOWN OR HOW DOES THAT
WORK?
>> NO, I DON'T SUSPECT THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THE FBI WILL PUT IT ON
HOLD.
THEY'LL TAKE THE STEPS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AUTHORIZES
THEM TO TAKE AND MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS, DESPITE THE POLITICAL
FUROR AROUND IT AND THE KIND OF
IMPASSIONED VIEWS ON BOTH SIDES.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM, ANDERSON, IS
THE DRAMA AND THE ATTENTION ON
THIS, SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
REVELATION POTENTIALLY OF
INFORMATION FROM THE AFFIDAVIT.
IT COULD HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT
ON PEOPLE'S DESIRE TO GET
INVOLVED IN THE INVESTIGATION.
SO THE NEXT TIME THE BUREAU GOES
OUT AND KNOCKS ON SOMEONE'S
DOOR, HAVING SEEN ALL OF THIS
PLAYED OUT IN THE MEDIA AND
FOUGHT OVER IN THE COURSE OF
THESE MOTIONS, IT'S MUCH LESS
LIKELY THAT PEOPLE WILL BE
WILLING TO JUST SIT DOWN AND